well thank you Bob for a reminder of
history I'm Anne I'm didn't yell for
three years relatively new department
chairman and this Bicentennial has been
a terrific event that I would recommend
based on my experience to all of the
department chairs here because my
business manager got on the case and
looked up the history of our department
and found at least three endowed chairs
that have been appropriated by other
departments so it's been a remarkably
rewarding experience and will continue
to provide rewards actually for all of
us I won't disclose which of the other
chairs will be hearing from us soon
actually to be serious for a moment it's
a it's a privilege to have a chance to
introduce Eric Kandel I'd like to
introduce him the way I met him the
first thing about Eric is the laughs you
exit the elevator when you want to visit
them on his floor and you pick it up as
soon as the door opens it goes through
walls it's totally unique maybe you'll
be lucky and be treated to to some of it
today you follow it to his office
through a rabbit warren of a floor with
equipment of all around and you find the
scientist who himself is quite unique
who harbors this really unique laughs
you're welcomed as you walk into his
office to an astounding view of the
Hudson but really what you've entered is
neuroscience central and you appreciate
that right away Eric is is without a
doubt the Pope of modern modern
neuroscience in his early work of rabbi
he made one of the greatest discoveries
in all brain science which is how memory
that the fact that memories are stored
in synapses and and how they're stored
in terms of changes in their strength
and size this is his early work in the
in the organism of pleasure he then went
on over several decades to elucidate for
us at a cellular molecular biochemical
level how this process of memory storage
occurs how synapses adjust their very
nature not just their strength in accord
with experience too
record that experience and most recently
he's taught us and continues to teach us
how these biochemical states can be
encoded in conformational switches of
proteins that are related to prions
now Eric's force of intellect and
personality apart from his own research
have enduringly transformed Columbia
into a powerhouse of neuroscience and
infusing virtually every department
that's biology related in the university
with both enthusiasm and with
exceptional faculty often captured in
their youth not too similar in a way to
what George Pilate did at Yale and his
historical influence on not just his
department which I'm privileged to chair
but on so much of what goes on here at
Yale but in service of a different field
namely cell biology Eric has given
generations of students is canonical
textbook principles of neuroscience and
most recently a as it were popular
autobiography and essay on neuroscience
which has rapidly become a must read for
scientists and non-scientists delight so
Eric we're honored to have you as the
first speaker in our symposium today a
very special symposium but especially
privileged to hear you speak first thank
you
thank you Jim for that marvelous
introduction I just wish my parents were
alive to hear it my father would have
enjoyed it my mother would have believed
it I think I speak for all of the
speakers that you've invited by saying
it's really a joy to participate in
year's Bicentennial the Angels in the
academic sections of heaven rejoice for
the particular pride when a great
institution carries on for 200 years I'm
going to begin by saying something about
the history of Medicine the DAL it is as
many of you probably know the sixth
oldest medical school of the United
States and that alone is extraordinary
but what is less known although if you
read the book on the Bicentennial that
the Dean has provided you with you will
rapidly learn that even though it was
the sixth oldest medical school it felt
it could not be outdone by the five
institutions that it started before it
and it went ahead and granted the first
md degree in the colonies so let me say
a little bit about that and to do that I
have to put the history of medical
education in the United States in
perspective the first medical school
established in the colonies was at the
unit the University of Pennsylvania in
1765 but the first nd degree granted to
somebody who actually went to the
Medical School and graduated from it a
man by the name of Robert Tucker was at
King's College later becoming Columbia
University and that was in 1770 but Yelp
beat them to all of us because it gave
the first MD
and he gave it to a person who not only
never attended the medical school but
never even came to the Americas then the
opportunity in 1723 not one could give a
whole lecture on this and I intend to do
so a century before Yale had a medical
school it awarded the MD degree to this
gentleman a British barber surgeon who
not only never attended the school but
never came to the Americas and how does
this come about there were two important
components a request in the bequest he
wrote to Yale and asked them whether
they would give him a medical doctorate
and he wrote in part this is the last
paragraph of a rather extended letter if
your Lordships judge me worthy of the
degree of Doctor of the Yale Academy and
here to transmit it to me as a diploma I
shall accept it not only as a token of
your gratitude but shall consider it an
honor as great as if it had been
conferred by another even more renowned
University Harold Varmus speaking of
more renowned welcome and he left a
bequest that consisted of 32 volumes but
actually with 25 books which really
still present in the library and had
among them several books that he had
written of course and the very famous
countless Illustrated anatomy of the
human body which was the first English
textbook which illustrations of the
human body now this represents a very
important tradition within yeah Yale
values scholarship above all and it
values books very deeply and at the
beginning what it needed was even more
than endowment was a great library and
simply to remind you in 1718 this is
five years before they granted Turner a
degree they actually gave the whole
College to Eli yeah
they changed the name of the college
from the collegiate school to Yale
College in return for his library so it
was in that spirit that they gave Turner
a degree and in retrospect we have to
say that this is a strategy that is paid
off beautifully 200 years later that
Harvey Cushing John J Whitney library is
generally considered one of the most
magnificent medical libraries in the
world so all of us joined in wishing you
a happy Bicentennial and many many more
books let me turn to the topic of my
talk which is on the perpetuation of
memory storage so I would like to
consider with you how one remembers
something for long period of time how
you remember your first love experience
for the rest of your life and let me put
memory storage into a bit of a
perspective for you it's convenient
divide the study of memory into two
major parts explicit memory and implicit
memory explicit is what you commonly
think of a memory it's a memory for
facts and events for people places and
objects and this involves the medial
temporal lobe and hippocampus this is
what h-m suffered from and it has a
characteristic feature that if you think
of your first love relationship you have
to make you conscious effort to think
about it requires conscious
participation this is in conscious the
implicit memory which is memory for
skills and habits for various kinds of
motor skills and perceptual skills
including elementary forms of learning
like a [ __ ] ooh a shin sensitization
class for conditioning and operant
conditioning this involves a family of
structures in the brain the amygdala for
emotional memory the cerebellum for
motor memory and in the simplest cases
which I'm going to refer to the reflex
pathways themselves and this has the
characteristic of not requiring
conscious attention and this is a very
interesting memory for example a de
Kooning when he had advanced Alzheimer's
disease could no longer remember most
things in his life could still paint
quite well and his paintings still we've
got millions of dollars when he sold
because he became so skilled that it
became almost a reflex when you and I
have a conversation with one another I
speak to you and you listen to me and we
presumably understand one another
because I hopefully speak grammatical
English I pay absolutely no attention to
the grammar in my language I don't know
where the down is where the verb is or
even whether there is a noun or verb in
the sentence so grammar has become in
all of our heads once we mature an
implicit skill my client and I have
studied this is essentially in three
organisms but I'm going to mention I'm
sorry in two organisms I'm gonna mention
a third so we've studied it initially
primarily in the snail but you can study
implicit memory it doesn't have
conscious recall and it's very good for
cell biological approach we made an
early attempt with calcic see and he's
continued with is to do some work on
cassava we can use genetics to study
behavior and I will tell you at the end
about working mice we can combine
genetics and circuit analysis to study
more complicated memory memory for an
explicit memory for space so let me
begin with the pleaseö the advantage of
apathy is that you have a hundred
billion neurons in your brain that's a
lot by conscious duplicity only has
about twenty thousand nerve cells these
are collected in clusters called ganglia
each ganglion has about two thousand
nerve cells and a single ganglion
controls not one but a whole bunch of
different behaviors so the number of
cells committed to a single behavior
that can be quite small in the limit 100
neurons or less not only are they few
cells but the cells are gigantic they're
the largest cells in the animal kingdom
so a cell like this is is a millimeter
in diameter I used to be able before I
became principal pic to see with my
naked eye moreover they're so
characteristic in their position in the
location pigmentation you can identify
them as unique individuals give them
names Joe Jim David and return to them
in every single animal of the species in
this simple animal with the simple
nervous system we studied the simplest
behavior
has is simple withdrawal reflex like the
withdrawal of a hand from a hot object
for the surgeons in the audience let me
simply point out that this is the head
of the animal this is its tail the
animal has a respiratory organ called
the Gill which is external and is
covered by a sheet of skin called the
mantelshelf and the siphon if you apply
a weak tactile stimulus to the siphon
you get a very brisk withdrawal of the
guilt very much like the past role of a
hand from a hot object now this simple
reflex we found to our astonishment can
be modified not by one several different
forms of learning in each of them gives
rise to both the short-term and
long-term memory
sensitization the situation classical
conditioning operant condition these are
the elementary forms of learning that
Parvati Parvat and Thorndike described
at the beginning of the 20th century we
focused a lot of our work on
sensitization a form of learn fear and
that's where I'm going to describe to
you now if you scare the hell out of an
animal by giving it a shock to the tail
further like that you come back and
apply a weak tactile stimulus incitement
of the kind that you did before
producing your modest reflex response it
now will produce a very powerful reflex
response because the animal has been
aroused but it's not just emulous and
therefore all of us reflexes are
enhanced the withdrawal itself lasts
four seconds but the memory of that
withdrawal carries on for Perez varying
from hours to weeks depending on the
number of reinforcing stimuli practice
makes perfect
even in the snails we worked at the
neural circuit of this behavior there
are twenty-four sensory neurons that
pick up from the syphon skin they make
direct connections to motor neurons that
connect directly to the gills so a very
important part of the reflex is a mono
synaptic connection between the sensory
neurons of the motor nerves moreover
these sensory neurons tile the siphon so
that if you touch just a single spot on
the siphon which we do you can limit the
activation to four to six sensory
neurons
they're also inhibitory and excitatory
antennas that modulate this reflux
because there is so few cells you can
not only studied in the intact animal in
the open of preparation but you can take
out individual sensor neurons individual
motor neurons put them at culture and
you can simulate the whole learning
process if you also include the
modulatory circuit which is critical for
learning when you stimulate the tail you
activate certain urge excels very
similar to the search energy canned
dopaminergic cells in your brain they
act on the sensory neurons including on
their terminals and they can regulate
the strength of synaptic connections if
you give a single tail shock which
produces a memory which lasts four
minutes you produce a transient
functional strengthening but if you give
five repeated tail shocks you produce a
memory that lasts four days this leads
to alterations in gene expression
involving CREB prominently as a
transcription factor and most
surprisingly a growth of new synaptic
connections so if you remember anything
about this lecture in fact if you
remember anything about the symposium
you will come out of this symposium with
a different head that you walked into in
fact you could argue it's a major
function of your medical school is to
change the brains of the people that
come there and turn is perfect testimony
to that so let me give you in very
simple terms our molecular understanding
of what happens so this is a sensory
neurone certain urge Excel pail shock
and this is the motor neuron if you
provide a single tail shock you activate
these certain urging cells they release
serotonin they activate a serotonin
sensitive receptor
coupled to an advil cyclase that
increases the level of cyclic GMP
activates the cyclic AMP eat dependent
protein kinase which phosphorylates
proteins in the presynaptic terminal
leading to an enhancement of transmitter
release from the presynaptic terminal
this is the mechanism of short-term
memory for the guilt withdrawal reflex
for sensitization if you give repeated
stimuli we showed about twenty years ago
on imaging experiments with Raja TN that
the catalytic subunit translocates to
the nucleus
in so doing it recruits another
the map kinase and they carry out a
double function the map kinase removes a
repressor and long-term memory CREP -
and cyclic AP dependent protein kinase
activates an activator CREB one now you
may say gee this is funny
having an inhibitory constraint the long
term memory why would you want that well
the fact is lots of things that you
learn lots of things and you'll counter
a trivial you don't want to put them
into long-term memory lots of things
that happen in life are miserable you
don't want to remember that forever if
you can possibly forget them so it has
to be an important event to get rid of
the repressor activate the activator
which then gives rise to the growth of
new synaptic connections this is turned
out to be a fairly general solution in
almost every situation where there's
what that long-term memory differs from
short-term memory involving
transcription almost invariably
involving prep is the key factor
although sometimes at the only factor
and giving rise to the growth of new
synaptic connections and that has raised
a real problem in the cell biology of
neurons if in fact long-term memory
involves transcription therefore the
nucleus which is an organelle that is in
principle in contact with every synapse
have been around does that mean all the
thousand synapses that a neuron mate
unnecessarily converted to the long-term
form every time you form a long-term
memory or can you have a transcription
dependent process that is nonetheless
synapse-specific
and this is a question that Kelsey
Montana Justin she was in my lab she
developed the new culture system rather
than culturing a sensory neuron with a
single motor neuron she cultured it with
two motor neurons quite far apart so she
could puff on serotonin on what set of
connections without touching the others
excuse me
she can now puff on serotonin as she
puffed it on once she got a transient
facilitation at this set of connections
she saw nothing at that set of
connections not surprising we had known
that short-term facilitation was
synapse-specific
but when she gave five pulses she
produced a persistent facilitation
lasted days and did involve
transcription she could block it with an
anti crabby antibody but there was
nothing at the other synapse that
clearly showed you can get a synapse
specific transcription dependent
long-term facilitation that did not
involve other synapses of neural and
raise the question how does this come
about
clearly a signal is going back to the
nucleus trip is activated does that mean
the gene products are only sent to this
set of terminals where the signal
initiated or the gene products go to all
terminals but only those that are marked
perhaps by short-term processes can use
those gene products productively so she
examined this in a falling experiment
she gave five kalsa serotonin to one set
of terminals nothing to the other and
she produced long-term facilitation so
this is ours and this led to almost
doubling of synaptic strength and it was
about 80% increase the number of
synapses nothing at the other bridge she
not repeated the experiment and in
addition to applying five pulses here
she gave a single pulse to the other
branch and she found she now captured in
reduced form long-term synaptic
facilitation the other branch so this is
about a 50% facilitation about 35%
increase in number of varicosities so
this is an interesting finding so
clearly gene products are being shipped
all over what was the nature of the
marketing signal that allowed it to be
captured so she repeated the experiment
she gave five pulses here a single pulse
there and she now she included an
inhibitor the cyclic GMP dependent
protein kinase and when she did that she
blocked the capture completely so
clearly one part of the marking signal
is phosphorylation by pk
but then she did an even more thoughtful
expert she applied five forces here a
single called
pulse here and she gave an inhibitor of
protein synthesis she applied this
locally said only effective to synapse
now she had known from Ossie Stuart's
work that there are at synapses
ribosomes and machinery for local
protein synthesis but would didn't know
exactly what the function of that was
and she found to a surprise that when
she gave inhibitor of protein synthesis
locally
she had the capture she had the growth
of new synaptic connections but this was
not maintained so 25 is later when you
already have full-blown long term
facilitation that was fine but over the
next 48 hours it collapsed so she
studied this more she used another
inhibitor rapamycin which is more
selective gave five pulses here one
pulse there and rapamycin inhibit of
local protein synthesis she saw the
facilitation but it did not persist she
wondered this is also happened at the
site of initiation where you have the
really large facilitation and she saw
that it does if you give five pulses
together with a premised beautiful
facilitation not maintained now the
interesting thing which i'm going to
show you is that these synapses which
have grown out those same synapses we
track unless they're appropriately
maintained by local protein synthesis
I like this experiment so much I'm going
to show it to you once again we're now
going to look at 24 hours we're going to
look at 72 hours at site of initiation
inside of temperature so this is the
site of initiation and this is the site
of capture so at 24 hours after giving
five pulses here and a single pulse here
you have nice facilitation in the side
of initiation and nice growth and even
at the set of capture you have perfectly
nice facilitation reduce and growth but
at 72 hours where you still maintain the
facilitation of growth the site of
initiation that never saw an inhibit of
local protein synthesis at the site of
capture where you inhibit protein
synthesis you lose the facilitation and
you lose the growth this is just
restating what I told you before so this
raises the question how does this come
about how do you regulate local protein
synthesis
and how do you maintain this and this is
what Cal 6e came along and almost
everything I'm gonna tell you in a
pleasure derived from his thinking of
the problem he argued look if you're
gonna send messenger knees to all the
processes you want them to be inhibited
in some ways you don't want the messages
to be active otherwise they might be
promiscuously activated at some
inappropriate synapse and one thing we
do not want that this Bicentennial is
inappropriate
promiscuous activation of messenger RNA
so he argued look example of this had
arisen with Joel Rita he had shown that
in maternal RNA in our sites in of his
oocytes you in fact have messages with
the short poly a tail but in the 3-prime
utr you have a six nucleotide sequence
called the cytoplasmic polyadenylation
element that binds a protein called the
cytoplasmic polyadenylation element
binding protein and this recruits the
poly a polymerase machinery which then
leads to the cytoplasmic polyadenylation
lengthening of the poly a tail which now
makes the message capable of translation
giving rise to protein so calcic asked
thus this kind of a protein exists in
the placenta and he found a
developmental isoform very similar to
which joel which they described but he
found a novel form of CPB which had
never previously described and it
differed from the conventional form in
three ways it is neurone specific you do
not find this in other tissues of the
body while the developmental isoform is
found at every tissue at the body
including the bread number one number
two it is not phosphorylated by the
aurora kinase it is activated by
serotonin leads to an increase in the
level of expression protein synthesis
and finally it has a peculiar and
terminal that i'm going to come to in a
moment
so cows explored this he applied a
single pulse of serotonin and saw that
in fact CPB was increased in this level
of expression just at the point where
the serotonin was applied this shows you
the increase and illiberal expression of
the protein this is block vomiting
is blackberry promise and it's
restricted to the point in which
serotonin is applied he then developed
an antisense oligonucleotide fused it to
a tad peptide which allows it to be
carried across the membrane and applied
it to one synapse and not to the other
so we have a control and we have the
experimental here he blocks EPP here
does not you see this is the control
side and this is the side which the anti
since illegal is applied and you see it
acts exactly like inhibitors of local
protein synthesis the facilitation is
established not but not maintained
moreover you don't need CPP active for
just a short period of time but as long
as we've been able to go and now we've
gone substantially beyond 48 hours you
need the active presence of CPB so that
raises the question what keeps this
going what is responsible for the
position action of CPB and he was of
course earlier struck with a peculiar
end terminal the end terminal of a
Paisley this is the first I had between
60 amino acids almost 50% of the
residues are Poland glutamine and
asparagine a number of people read and
susan linguist had early described that
domains of the sort
now found in yeast proteins that have
pre unlock properties and I showed too
well studied prion proteins their
domains here this is the implicit domain
and calcic immediately pull out to the
Sala or to RA and show that had very
similar set of polar residues this
differs dramatically from the typical
aplenty proteins which have a lot of
charged residues and very few polar
residues well what's so interesting
about prion proteins well there are
three properties is you probably know
very well they can exist in two
conformational States
monomeric and aggregated only one of
these is active the aggregated form and
the aggregated form is self-perpetuating
so it can interact with the inactive
form the monomeric form caused it to
undergo a conformational change so you
can either be recruited to the aggregate
or form aggregates on
so Kasich asked the question is this
also true for plenty of CPP he developed
an asset that he put into yeast he fused
CPB they Express CP being yeast cells
together with a reporter contract which
had the cpe element to which it normally
binds fused to beta down and he
expressed this in these cells and he saw
most cells were blued missus carried for
generation to generation but occasional
cells are white they were carried
forward from generation to generation
but there was an inter conversion it's
low rates but significantly faster than
spontaneous mutation rates between the
blue cells and the white cells and the
white cells and the blue cells so this
is a guess that that this was binding
and this may be the aggregated form and
this is the diffuse form and he wanted
to visualize this so if he fused CPB to
gfp and visualized that he saw that in
the white cells it was diffused as if it
might be soluble a monomeric form and
the blue cells have formed aggregates
consistent with it being the aggregated
form and so wanted to see whether or not
you could trigger the conformational
change in the soluble form so it becomes
the aggregated form any Caroline
experiment which is well-known in these
which is called subduction in which you
can use mutant strains of yeast in which
you can have cytoplasmic fusion without
nuclear fusion so he fused the blue
cells to the white cells in the
situation which you don't have an ending
a fusion and he saw that the blue
protein moved into the white cells and
converted all of the white protein to
blue this simply shows you what the
phenotypes blue cells made at the white
Zod's
become blue so this suggested to us a
model that we're still exploring to the
moment the Five Forces serotonin you set
up a retrograde signal to the nucleus it
activates creb gene products both
proteins and messenger RNAs are sent to
all the terminals the marked terminals
used the proteins immediately and use
the messages with a delay the marking
signal consists of at least two compose
pKa and activation of pi3 kinase which
Kasich was found was essential
activating the translation of CPP we
posit without any evidence whatsoever
that CPP initially is an a' monomeric
soluble form and then it becomes
transformed in ways we don't yet
understand the plays here but I will
show you later on we have some insight
from eyes to become the aggregated form
the aggregate form is the form that
binds to the CP element gives rise to
cytoplasmic polyadenylation gives rise
to translation gives rise to the
messengers in poke that gives us to the
proteins necessary for the stabilization
of the anatomical changes so this seemed
to us a very interesting problem because
it suggested to us that we might be
dealing with a new class of prion
proteins all proteins prions that we
looked at before are not regulated in
any known fashion
certainly not by physiological signals
number one and number two when they move
into the aggregated form they either
kill the cell or they become dead
proteins this was the first suggestion
that number one these prion like
proteins could respond to physiological
signals in this case serotonin and once
they were in the aggregated form they
did something good for the cell they had
a functional purpose so we wanted to see
you know this is also applied when we
look at CPP in neurons does CPP behave
in neurons like it does in yeast and is
it essential for perpetuation so the
first thing we did is over express CPP
and sensory neurons fuse the GFP and you
can see very discreet aggregates form
and if you chopped off the prion domain
you lost that you can take the prion
domain and put it on the developmental
isoform which normally does not form
aggregates but the rest of the coding
sequence is almost the same in Niagra
form aggregates their serotonin modulate
aggregate formation this is the
expression of
CPP fused to gfp care
over period of 36 hours and we now do
the same thing if they have been giving
pulses of serotonin you see a dramatic
increase in number of arguments is it
important for facilitation we had a
number of strands that I only show you
one calcic developed is antibody that
was specific to the aggregated form this
is the control this is in which the
antibody was ejected and it selectively
but that maintains the long-term
facilitation so this suggested that CP
be consistent aggregated form in that
aggregate form is a prerequisite for
long-term facilitation and causes to ask
is this also important in memory so
counselor got interested in flies while
he was still in my lab worked with Gary
Stewart began to show that in fact the
fly homolog is very very similar to a
pleasure in many dimensions and we were
about to do behavioral experiments when
we got scooped by a very beautiful
experiment but Barry Dixon who read the
official papers he answered the question
that I posed in the first time do you
remember your first love experience for
the rest of your life now most of the
gentlemen in the audience probably don't
have an experience that I have but if an
inexperienced male is rejected by an
experienced female Jim I'm sure this
never happened to you he remembers that
for the rest of his life and this holds
true in flies as well as in people and
Barry examined this he looked at
short-term memory in flies both
wild-type flies and flies that had one
or both alleles lacked out of CPB and
flies in which only the prion domain was
knocked out and nothing else here is a
wild-type fly showing long-term memory
not got a single allele long-term
memories reduced knockout both alleles
long-term memories gone not got only the
prion domain and most of the long-term
memories gone Kasich has continued with
this and even shown more that CPB has
very similar functions and this causes
to turn to mice and ask this also apply
to explicit memory storage in mice
you probably know mice it's very easy to
study spatial memory they have very
strong spatial memory and as you know
they have a campus is involved in it and
hippocampus gives rise to changes in
synaptic strength called long-term
potentiation and one can explore these
things the first thing we look is what
sort of isoforms of CPP are there in the
mouse are there mammals in general and
we found that there's not simply one but
there are four which in a moment of
great creativity recalled CPP one two
three and four and CPB one is the
developmental isoform which we studied
with Joe Lister and two three and four
new forms of these on various tests we
found that CP b3 is closest to the
aphasia form it has no where the polar
residues that that you see in
invertebrates but this is true for
mammalian prions in general it has 18%
of the first 150 amino acids that that I
have a polar residues we pop this into
yeast and we saw unlike other CPP's CPB
three form clusters very similar to the
implicitly CPB moreover when we looked
at it in hippocampal neurons and culture
replied the excitatory transmitter
glutamate we've sought clusters formed
in areas that appear to be postsynaptic
dendrite then exponents we then examine
in detail where CPP 3 located using a
presynaptic marker to localize it to
synapses we use enough devices you can
see very clearly CPP 3 this is a nap
device they're in beautiful opposition
to one another we were able to identify
some of the targets of CP b3 which
include things that have been clearly
identified but Mallett now Roger Nicole
and others is being critical for a long
term memory in the mouse glue or one
glue or two and familiar
we now have generated a number of mice
English still studying them this is
we've not finished with them we've said
it in detail with Joe Victor and not get
a CPP wonder that's practice
no phenotype we've studied the dominant
negative of 1 2 4 which does have a
phenotype but this knocks out all 4 of
them and we're now just beginning to
analyze a CPB 3 knock out and a knock in
without a pea under me we have some
preliminary data on the CPB 3 knock of
which I'll show you in a moment if you
look at knockout of all four you find a
clear deficit in the late phase of LTP
and a clear memory deficit we're just
beginning to analyze the knock out of CP
b3 but from the physiology alone and the
behavior it's very early looks somewhat
similar much in the phenotype that we
see with the dominant negative
inhibition of war 4 can be accounted for
by knockout of this single gene now
clearly we're dealing with a molecule
that is explosive and we wondered how
could it be regulated and due to the
work of allies Papadopoulos in my lab
we've encountered an interesting
mechanism of its regulation what lies
found is that CP b3 is regulated by
neuralyzed which EU Bickford enlarged
a's and he originally found that CP b3
I'm sorry he was not studying CP 3 he
was studying ubiquitin ligase in
drosophila he found that over expressing
this particular ubiquitin ligase
neuralyzed enhanced memory in drosophila
so he came to my land being interested
in studying neuralyzed and i really had
no interest in neuralyzed
but elijah is a very bright guy I
thought if he hangs around the lab
sooner or later he will get convinced by
others to study CPP and he didn't have
to get convinced he found that CP b3 is
in fact a target analyzed ubiquitin
ligase often involved in degradation but
also can be involved in the activation
of protein spread mono your big relation
and he found that CP b3 is activated by
neuralyzed
through your big donation and this is
the model been using I show you at the
first point how we think about it and
then I'm trying to provide some of the
data that with this model is based upon
neuralyzed
turns over very rapidly in the basal
state and CP b3
is inhibited is in fact a repressor of
translation in the basal state when you
activate the synapse you slow down the
turnover of neuralyzed it translocation
becomes physically associated with CP b3
and it does it through the prion domain
of CP b3 it leads to the Monica creation
the leads to the recruitment of the poly
polymerase complex the polyadenylation
complex leads to the polyadenylation
leads to the translation of familial
glue or one of the war two and the
maintenance of synaptic strength let me
show you some of the data this is based
upon the lie is found that neurologists
co-localize together with CP b3 and
dendrites and both of them both CP B 3
and neuralyzed an opposition to synaptic
icing so this is the synaptic icing
which I showed you before this is
neuralyzed
in relationship to synaptic vicen this
is CP b3 in relationship to synaptic
icing they similar have relationship to
them if you look at them together you
see that neural eyes and CPB 3 are
superimposable on one another
moreover they physically associated if
you do an ant if you do a pull-on
experiment from these cells with anti CP
b3 antibody you pull down both proteins
but if you're not got the prion domain
you no longer have an interaction
between CP b3 in neurons so the prion
domain is critical for the interaction
he now generated two lines of mice that
overexpress neuralyzed and he saw that
in both of them CP b3 was increased
integrated work fashion so this is the
line in which this weaker expression
this language this greater expression so
there was a great an increase in CP b3
while CP 1 and CP before were not
affected so this is a pet line this is
completely reversible he then looked at
the targets the known targets of CP b3
familial or two and grew of one and
similarly found a greater increase in
them in this simply shows you that it's
completely reversible when you give dogs
and then in order to get a little bit
more direct evidence although this is by
no means a perfect experiment he made it
these neuralyzed overexpressing
to see whether or not this connection is
causal with the mice that expressed the
dominant negative and Hitler for all
four so the ideal thing which we in the
process of doing is mating it to the
knockout of of just cpp three alone but
this is a dominant negative overall for
and those circumstances you in fact find
you reverse the action of paralyze
everything that you saw in control comes
back so it acts as if you're not over
expressing their lives so this is
consistent with the fact that nur
Eliza's acting suit through CPB three if
you looked at physiology of the
neuralyzed overexpressing mice you saw
that they have enhanced LTP and the mice
are absolutely brilliant so by the third
training trial they're way ahead of
controls they remember much better in
long terms that they v the the wild-type
mice have caught up but the mutants are
still significantly ahead after they
trouble of training all the animals have
couch F caught up but if you're not wait
a few days without further training
again the long-term memory of the
neuralyzed overexpressing mice is
enhance this holds not only for spatial
memory for other members as well
long-term memory that involves the
hippocampus is significantly it means
moreover in the neural lives
overexpressing mice you see an increase
in branch structure in increase of
number of dendritic spines so this
suggested to us a very direct test I
mean our model is that neuralyzed needs
to the money it physically interacts
with its free under mean with with the
prion domain of CP B 3 that neuralyzed
interacts with the prion domain of CP b3
leads to the monitor backwardation of CP
b3 endlessly B monitor BIC related CP B
3 that recruits the poly a polymerase
machinery etc etc is responsible for the
maintenance of synaptic connections so
he tested this being hippocampal
cultures carrying out all the critical
experiments seeing whether or not is CP
b3 just money you back when ad would be
able to mediate the long-term process so
when he looked in the control case he
saw these are hippocampal neurons in
culture he saw a certain number of
dendritic branches if you now Express CP
b3 which in this basal state is a
repressor you lost some of those than
for the branches if you expressed neural
eyes which in principle allows money
back relation you increase the number of
gender exponents if you got rid of the
prion domain of CP b3 you lost the
increase in drugs
if you got rid of the ligase domain in
neural eyes you're also lost it but if
you take CP b3 and just money a paper
native do nothing else and express it in
hippocampal neurons you get a very nice
growth of synaptic connections so this
leads to sort of several conclusions one
that I think evidence is becoming
reasonably good although by no means
completely convincing is yet that there
is a new class of prions emerging from a
Perseus CPB Drosophila up to B and the
mousy pb3
i should say that susan Rehnquist has in
the past year taken the implicitly CP B
and studied extensively in yeast showing
gives rise to strains every single
feature of these bands she's been able
to duplicate with the implicit CP B so
we think this is a new type of prion of
functional prion that it may not be
uniquely used for learning they might be
used in other contexts as well that's an
addiction in development other things
that require long term maintenance and
it's two distinctive features which I
mentioned to you before is that
serotonin a physiological single
converted from the monomer to the
aggregated form and that the aggregated
form is perpetuating and function and
finally this is clearly a highly
regulated process and we're just
beginning to see the nature of the
regulation I did not describe to you
Priya Rajat Sassoon's an MD PhD students
work in my lab that is shown that is
regulated by thickly by particular micro
RNA the
form in the mouse I showed you that cp3
is activated by neuralyzed through the
crow nation we now have preliminary
evidence that it is repressed by
simulation d aggregate a consumer
relation so this really I think has
turned out to be an extremely
interesting example of fact that it
contributes importantly to the
stabilization of volunteer memory and
let me simply end by thanking my
colleagues this work was started by
Kelsie Martin the implicit work was
completely cleared out by Cal sexy and
the mouse worked largely by by live
Papadopoulos he had help from Pietra
Follette and the one FM teeny and also
from fit in under and Martin
Susan linguist helped us with our
plaisir studies in with contact weather
all the time
Wayne Hendrickson a McDermott helped us
with structural studies we have reason
to believe that these functional prions
have a different structure than
conventional prions we have reason to
believe that they do not form beta
sheets they form coils and we now have
some preliminary evidence to sort of
support that but we've got a long way to
go on that and we collaborated with CPP
one and Joe Richter and thank you very
much